Hey guys my name is Markiplier I've got a very important announcement we're gonna be doing a charity livestream for save the children starting tomorrow
At 10 a.m.
Pacific standard time
but this isn't gonna be a normal charity live stream this one is bigger and better than anything we've ever done before
I've been setting up the live stream equipment all day, we've been like collecting the necessary
Materials to be able to do all of the challenges that we have in store and it's gonna be more fun than just normal challenges
because we've got all this stuff that we're gonna be doing in front of you and live we're gonna be making breakfast
with a twist we're gonna be dodging arrows we're gonna be on going on an easter egg hunt
with shock collars we're gonna play jenga with muscle stimulators we're gonna be playing cards against humanity' we're gonna be doing an ice bath
reading your comments we're gonna be doing
blindfold friend yoga which is just something that i made up doesn't even exist we're gonna be doing body art with blow pens
And on top of all of that
I've got a board of 24 unique punishments
Because every milestone that we reach we're going to be doing another
punishment and every loser of these challenges that we got here we're going to be doing another  punishment and if we hit
milestones in time we've even got five
additional
unlockable punishments here that you can see us suffer through but more importantly
Above all else above the punishments above the challenges this one is extremely important because this one's for save the children
which is a very important charity by itself but also an anonymous donator has agreed to match
every donation made up to two hundred
Thousand dollars and two hundred thousand dollars is our goal this time around which if you know is higher than it's ever been before
Which, is why it's so important that you guys join us on this charity livestream tomorrow and not only that it's so important that you
spread the word about it we've planned this whole day of fun and amazing
horrible, terrible things that we have in store for you here
but it's gonna be a lot of fun and for a great cause because everything that you donate tomorrow
everything that you do tomorrow is double.
Every other viewer that you get in the stream that can possibly donate that effect is
Compounded every donation that you make is matched the entire stream
Every action that you take to try to make this world a better place is gonna be doubled tomorrow
So please join us for a day full of fun we're all gonna be here and it's gonna be nonstop fun
So thank you everybody
So much, for watching all the available information is down in the description below and so hopefully we will see you tomorrow
So thank you everybody, so much for watching and As Always I'll see you, in the next video buh-bye
That's bob we're gonna be bobbing by the way ice bucket bob apples great, okay, cool
(hi the subtltler waz Ben Ranking!!)